[Musik]
macht ihr denn hier eine scheiße
der jahresrückblick das habe ich völlig
vergessen jetzt ja ist ja ist aber auch
ein scheiß dato muss ganz ehrlich sagen
so kurz vor heiligabend noch
erledigungen machen
ja ich könnte euch jetzt mitnehmen dass
wir es einfach so im laufen machen dann
machen wir es so ja kommt ja 2020
ja da passiert war oder was war das für
ein ja also ich meine gibt es jemanden
der jahre produziert so was wie einen
weltgeist also wenn es jemanden gibt der
jahre produziert dann muss man immer
sagen hör auf zu kiffen so fokussiere
ich mal was dann los junge cracks
händler maßen verpacken
ich meine als wärst du schwer so ein
jahr weltgeschichte zu bauen
der letzte mal hier was schlimmes
passiert ja was schönes da machen wir im
dezember in der schleife drum
und dann sagt markus lanz zur karl
lauterbach herr lauterbach
ich habe da ein spannendes zitat von
ihnen gelesen
das wäre ein solides tüv geprüftes
standard jahr wenn der welt kreis danach
in der chronik blättern und sagt der
papa ist schuld sondern ja mach ich dir
an einem wochenende aber der feine herr
weltgeist stellte bogen zimmer mir klar
dann einfach mal eine pandemie falle
einer völlig neuen unbekannten krankheit
so unbekannte sie erst mal denken so
schlimm wird ja nicht sein
eine gute sache hatte bewohner ist hat
noch mal genau gezeigt worin wir als
menschen gut sind und mit neuen
situation umgehen gehört definitiv nicht
dazu wie träge wir in deutschland waren
als wir gehört haben
da gibt es in china ein echt
ansteckendes virus und alle so yeah
china also ich meine diese verträge auch
kein bier also klar daher geht bestimmt
aus den sie belaufen schnupfen wie wir
emotionale nun mit globalisierung zu tun
haben und da gibt es immer mehr meldung
dass das virus echt gefährlich ist und
sich schnell ausbreitet und alle in
deutschland so ja ok aber du solltest zu
uns kommen also sein wie ostchina ist
mehrheit weg und dann ist es irgendwann
in italien und man weiß italien geht es
gerade richtig scheiße damit und alle
deutschen denken
ja gut ist scheiße detail aber ist immer
ein bisschen scheiße in italien es ist
anfang märz zwei wochen vor dem lokal
denken sich drei viertel aller deutschen
immer noch hier kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass es mit diesem virus in
deutschland ein thema wird man kann ist
ende märz und alle merken das virus
befällt auch deutsche ja wie unhöflich
sind alle so klar da brauchen werden
die hab ich ja schon vor wochen gesagt
na klar aber die politiker innen würde
ich ja immer wieder nicht
pappnasen ja und dann ist lockdown und
experten waren schon da
von einer zweiten welle und dann ist
sommer und deutsche arbeiten und
experten warnen und deutschland machen
urlaub und experten warnen
und dann kommt die zweite welle und also
nicht das hat mir nicht kommen sehen und
die experten ihr habt also wir schauen
wir hatten ja gewarnt
ja gut ja experten warnen ja immer das
hat der job aber so als otto normal
ignoriere es ist schon eine überraschung
wo ich das genau ist ich war ja selbst
einer von denen ja bei corona wird auch
vieles übertrieben original meinung aus
dem märz dieses jahres wenn ich die
meinung dass heute durchgezogen hätte
würde ich mir jetzt ein telegramm kanal
mit dem wendler teil
alle mussten sich durch die pandemie die
frage stellen was ist uns als
gesellschaft eigentlich wichtig und da
ist uns aufgefallen
makler innen brauchen wir jetzt gerade
nicht so dringt also habe ich jetzt noch
nicht gehört dass menschen weit auf der
straße stand
ich dachte nicht uns jetzt für zwei
monatsmieten die tür von dieser neuen
wohnung aufnehmen gemerkt leute die in
krankenhäusern arbeiten
die sind wichtig also wirklich richtig
erklären also jetzt auch nicht so
wichtig dass man sagt wir wollen den so
viel geld geben wenn jemand herr
maschinen baut
als er dann will ja auf einmal jeder
menschen zu legen und dann gibt es
irgendwann vielmehr die pflegen wollen
als die ihn gepflegt werden müssen aber
die mehrheit war der meinung der schutz
von menschen ist superwichtig deswegen
machen wir die grenzen dicht und alle
bleiben zu hause
also es sei denn du wirst ausgebeutet
weil spargel stechen
denn spargel ist systemrelevant und
ausbeutung die meinen man hätte ja auch
sagen können bezahlen so viel lohnen
dass auch deutsche lust haben acht
stunden lang auf den knien rutschen
kostet der spargel halt zehn euro pro
pfund
hast du diesen sommer nur zweimal
gebissen aber da sagt die regierung nein
jeder deutsche hat das anrecht auf
mindestens viermal stinkend in allen
monaten mit den buchstaben aber was war
schön
es gab eine völlig neue entwicklung in
deutschland der wurden leute sehr
bekannt weil sie ahnung haben von dem
was sie da machen wir kennen christian
drosten weil er einer der führenden
virologen in deutschland ist ein video
von miley nun kämen ist das meist
gesehene des jahres weil sie
wissenschaft sehr gut erklären kann
die deutschen uhr sahin und öffnen türen
sie finden ein impfstoff menschen die
mega berühmt wurden weil sie kompetenz
haben erzählt dass man dem sommer aus
der stars kompetenz ich bin nach dem
bachelor geworden wie geil wäre das wenn
da einfach nur noch sehr kluge leute
eingeladen würden ja also ich nominiere
professor dr sloterdijk für den auszug
aus dem haus weil ich seine gegenwart
analyse keinen neuen gedanken abgewinnen
kann
was uns dieses jahr nicht so gut
gelungen ist rassismus kleinreden der
reihe die standard meinung von vielen
ich bin rassismus schlimm glaube aber
nicht dass deutschland damit ein problem
hat
es gab eine umfrage in der deutschen
gefragt wurden ob sie ein problem hätten
mit racial profiling also damit dass die
polizei einen wegen der hautfarbe
häufiger kontrolliert und da haben wir
eben 63 prozent der befragten gesagt das
ist kein problem für mich
wenn da nichts auffällt das teil des
problems das gleiche institut hat
übrigens gern sie gefragt was sie für
die größte bedrohung unserer zeit halten
überraschung klimawandel ist nur auf
platz drei auf platz zwei fuchs auf
platz eins weihnachten racial profiling
war gar nicht dabei
der innenminister mahnte es sollte keine
studie über rassismus in der polizei
geben weil die nicht rassistisch ist
logisch einfach bei der nächsten
polizeikontrolle sagen ich möchte keine
alkoholtest machen weil ich nüchtern bin
dann sind immer mehr rechtsextreme
gruppen aufgetaucht bei der polizei und
nach seehofer da gesagt ja okay wir
machen eine studie aber nur wenn man
auch eine über den stressigen
arbeitsalltag der polizei macht denn das
muss man ja zusammen sehen wer kennt das
nicht du hast einen stressigen tag tritt
in der pfütze hast vergessen milch
einzukaufen und dann denkst du dir wenn
ich jetzt kein türke klatsche komme ich
aus dem gleichgewicht
sowohl das vor wurde die fahrt geht ja
das ist übrigens region nach der steht
hier aber auch bestimmt hier in der
kommentarspalte und da muss ich sagen so
wie du dich für die polizeieinsätze bin
ich froh dass die guten leute bei der
polizei dich vor mir schützen oder
umgekehrt
rassismus ist sogar bestandteil unserer
kultur dass man nicht weiß dass man
nichts weiß
ich musste diesen sommer lernen von
deutschland gegen schon vor dem
holocaust zwei völkermordes an den
herero und an den namen mindestens
50.000 menschen sind da ermordet worden
ich bin 35 ich habe abi und
politikwissenschaft studiert ich habe
das wort nahm dieses jahr das erste mal
gehört
wir haben in unserem geschichtsbuch zwei
seiten über kolonialismus tenor da hat
deutschland leider nicht so viel
abbekommen
das zu denken also auch rassismus
das ist peinlich weiß ja gar nicht so
schlimm dass man den moment der
selbsterkenntnis mal aushält denn das
leben geht ja direkt danach wieder
privilegiert weiter stößt
wir haben
keine kosten und mühen gehabt beim zdf
cool leute ich mach's cosi muss auch
geschenke holen macht uns doch ein
geschenk abonniert den kanal
guckt euch die videos an und wer da
keinen bock drauf hat klickt hier waren
sonst ehrlich gesagt egal
vielen dank scheiße der schwager